hey guys I want to talk about fruit on a
ketogenic diet a lot of questions come
up with that the answer is no okay let
me explain one it has too much sugar
even an apple has 19 grams of sugar
that's a median Apple they even came up
with something called a Honey Crisp
which is only 20 years old and they
modified it to the point where it has
tremendous amounts of fructose if you
consume that Apple it's incredibly sweet
versus apples the original Apple which
is kind of very tart pineapples are very
very very sweet wild strawberries are
not very sweet while blueberries are not
very sweet compared to the ones you buy
at the store and you never ever ever
want to consume fruit juices why because
the fiber it is attached is bound to the
phytonutrients so you get rid of the
fiber you're getting rid of a lot of the
nutrients Plus this juice is pasteurized
it's cooked
so anything that potentially could be
left is pretty much killed especially
the enzymes in that future so you're
basically getting a concentrated
concentrated fructose sugar a lot of
times they add corn syrup to it right so
you don't want to give your kids the
fruit juice you can give your kids fruit
because your metabolism is there and it
can burn up pretty fast just as an adult
I wouldn't consume much fruit especially
for trying to lose weight but you can I
recommend berries that's fine if it's
like in small amounts one half cup to
one cup of berries per day but I like to
put it in the Calais and I think that's
totally fine now
fructose itself just so you know the
sugar fructose it can lead to insulin
resistance it can lead to a fatty liver
and it can spike your blood sugars even
more than glucose okay alright thanks
for watching hey you probably already
subscribed but if you haven't press this
little button down below
and I will keep you updated